τοπου σας έκανε να σχοληθείται με των εριθροστμε τον ερηθό σταυρώ εξεκίνησαν το χιλιανιακόσιαβδομητατρία με
τομ μήμα νέον του ερλιθού σταγού το χιλιανιακόσαδομητα τέρα έγιναι το παξικόπημα και ισβολή και
είδα ότι ο εδός σταυρός ήταν μια οργάνωση που μπορούσε να προσφέρει σε παραπολού στομίς
απο ξέρεται ο ελθός αγός έπιαξε μεγάλο γόλο μετμετά την ισβολή ήταν τώρα έχουμε και
πενήντα χρόνια φέτος δεν υπήρχαν και πολλές οργανώσεις τότε αλλά ήταν υπεύθυνη τότε για τους
πρόσφυγες για τους όλους τς είχαν ήταν σστους καταβλισμούς ήταν στην ξενόχιξενοδοχειακής χολί εκεί που
έχουντα πίσω ιόλοι που ήταν φυλακή στην τουχκία και μετα εβοηθούσε όλους τους εγκλοβισμένους γι
ότι τότε είχεν και παραπολους το αραβεβαίω σε μειωθεήκαν αλλά από το χίλια κρο θα
βιμετα τέσσρα και μετά είναι ο ελιθός θαυγός που κοιτάζει τους εγκλοβισμένους και τους στέλνουν
διάφογα πράματα που χρειάζοα που διάβαζα ότι ήταν μια επίσκεψη σας σε ένα καταβλισμό που
σας έκανε να νιώσετε την απόγνωση αυτό των ανθρώπων και δραστηροποιήθηκάτε ακόμη εντονώτερα ναι γι
αυτό αυτό είναι αλήθεια τότε που επίγαμε επγια την πρό αυτύφογας τους καταυλιεμούς παγματικάπαθασώκ και
ενιώθα μεγάλη απογνωσή και είπα και είδα ότι εμπογούσαμε να βοηθήσουμε τον κόσμο στα μετρα
το δυνα το ότι των βεβαίος γιότι